[Music]
kind of while we're in the zone of
replying to people
and reading comments and replying to
comments for the whole i want you to go
ahead
yeah i wanted well i always wanted to
kind of take a second to give a sincere
thank you
to all the
um
bed mechanics and bed frame engineers oh
yeah in our audience big shot i had no
idea that there were so many
with with so loaded with so many
opinions on how i should
conquer the bed slant issue that i have
no you sleep like [ __ ] cause your
sleeping for him sucks stupid
your sleeping form is ass
you didn't learn how to sleep right
dummy some the best part about is all
the people that were like just turn
around just turn around
i don't know then i just have the
[ __ ] reverse issue
then i
yeah exactly oh this is way better
yeah no this is fake yeah
yeah no just turn around just put your
head at the foot of the bed
oh
[Music]
so then i'd be like this
[Laughter]
and then all the blood would go to my
feet
[Laughter]
yeah get a wedge pillow
get a wedge pillow this most sexual
thing you could suggest
my mom has one
get a w what was that what was that bed
that all those like family vloggers were
using to like get boned on
oh oh oh uh
oh what was that thing called
um
what the [ __ ] was that called it was the
children's toy yeah right some something
like that
it was like um it wasn't a bed i thought
it was like the i thought it was like a
wedge something
oh god that was so funny did we talk
about that on the podcast yeah
but bro but he found like somebody
infiltrated uh it was it's basically
like this children's
like matte thing that you can like
velcro together and like they you kids
used to like build forts but parents
used to [ __ ] on it all the time and so
like there was this whole underground
community of parents in this facebook
facebook group
it was called like some the name of the
toy after dark
and they would all talk about how they
[ __ ] on it
yeah their kid's toy
i mean i'm pretty sure kids toys double
up there was this creepy ass little toy
yeah the nugget this thing
the yeah nuggets
sounds like scat play
there's this little
toy i forgot what it was it was like a
vibrating bug i know i've talked about
it before let me look up the name of
this
cody tried checking if his bed has
turned into a ramp by using a level i
did i did that too i did that too but
it's not that obvious you know what i'm
saying it's like in the middle
dude you don't know how to use a leveler
with the weight that's when you feel it
it's not just the weight of a level
shows that it's level but it's not
just cody one of your links in your
slotted bed frame is broken that's why
your bed is slanted i'm sure you'll find
some strange rubber thing on the floor
see that's what i think it is
that's what i think it is and let me
also tell you this hold on my camera
turned off again but i'm just gonna keep
going
let me tell you this
the people did i tell you this part the
people that made
my bed frame
said that it was faulty did i tell you
that no
yeah so more info
you're here to hear first folks
this is a turn in the story just when
you thought
it's all on cody
it appears
the bed frame is faulty
[Music]
it's it's they they called me they were
like hey we we gotta like the all the
bed friends that came out of the factory
during this time are faulty and we have
to have a guy come in and fix it and we
said nah it's fine
and then slowly the [ __ ] my mattress
started slanting and so now i'm gonna
have the guy come in and fix it i don't
know if the it's related but i'm
assuming it is and i'm assuming it's
what this guy said
so there you go you were right
so suck on that and then and then and
then all the people that said flip the
mattress you're supposed to flip the
mattress every six months i've never
flipped a [ __ ] mattress in my entire
life and i've never had this problem
have you no
you've never flipped the mattress right
never
did they didn't tell you when you bought
the mattress at the mattress store that
you're supposed to flip the mattress
every six months
what do you mean you don't know that
obvious fact that everyone in the world
knows you're supposed to flip mattresses
everyone [ __ ] knows that bro
mattresses are not tires you don't
rotate them every certain amount of
sleeps stupid
yeah
you know you know what i actually
you know what i actually think you're
supposed to do
flip it vertically and sleep on the top
oh yeah because then you can fully just
bend on both sides
exactly yeah just like a nice little
exactly bro
the hex bug is what i was trying to
bring up in relation to the child
it's like a vibrating little bug toy
i remember yo pull these up pull these
up
it's like a vibrating little bug lit
literally how else would you describe
that vibrating little bug literally
i don't know it was just really funny to
hear you say that it's like the head of
a vibrating toothbrush but just the
brush part okay got it so
i remember this
uh
someone
i don't want to call them out but
someone basically bought a set of these
at my first dev job
and they stayed in the box for a while
and no one thought twice about it
so during like a all-nighter someone got
bored and and built out the toy i
remember coming back to the office the
next day
and a couple of engineers were like
chuckling and they're like hey noel
you uh
you give the hex hex bug a try i was
like the what
i walk over and i like they turn one on
and everyone's like dying laughing going
like what's so funny and then it like
rolls over and it just looks like the
top of a vibrator and i was like this is
fussy
i know these go missing
like i know these go missing
and this [ __ ] is just straight up it's
like a like i it sounds like a sex toy
company was like we can make money two
ways
smart and yeah that's very smart it's
got a it's just got a ball bearing in
there and it just goes oh it's for pets
this is for pets only
no
[Music]
no the thing we had it was like
you had like a little arena that you put
them in they're supposed to fight
there's no way this is a pe what
i'm learning new things here bro
let's see vibration sensory vibration
towards it read the reviews i bet
there's one in here this should make me
come in ten minutes
for kids i bet you there's a rating here
kids and cats
review from human and cat perspective
uh
please play by yourselves
keep going
not sure i can live with the shame
wait
not sure i could live with the shame i
bought these critters to go with the hex
bug loop
uh i bought these to entertain our cats
but mostly me
what
i was hooked on hex bugs when i bought
the first one six years ago in a toy
shop
i in hood river oregon the rest of my
party i played with it at table during
dinner
but shoot i was 68
and pretty much figured i was entitled
to have some fun the rest is a story for
toys anonymous whose grandma is this
you're sick up to spinners at 74. what's
there what are spinners oh look up
spinners man
you freak what is toys anonymous what is
her name what
does she is she still on facebook
can you click on her username and see
what else she's reviewed because
that could be good
yeah i need her at
150 reviews bro the irony she's in
beaverton oregon
oh my god let me go let me head up to
beavertown let me see what's going on
with this grandma
oh she's hopping into vr too oh she's a
she's a freak i need her
i need her
you nasty you nasty nasty woman dude
she's getting into video games look at
that i have not had this much fun since
1983 when we owned an atari 400 brah she
uh she's a vintage gamer girl
yeah
bet her hair is purple
let's go let's get some more reviews
from the hex bug see i'm not i don't
make [ __ ] up bro
i know there's someone listening to this
being like no one would have used that
for yes
yes they do
um
we got one more
good quality incredibly fun to play with
you're lying you did not buy these for
grandchildren
fun but not lasting uh
okay great play value
over half had flat batteries all right
whatever i thought that would be too
juicy i thought we'd get more
the hex bug got to be the nastiest
but yeah anyway speaking of [ __ ] kids
toys
oh she upgraded to sp she was not going
off with fidget spinners no way
she was [ __ ]
yeah
[Laughter]
that's messed up bro